we're witnessing the economic and
political meltdown of Venezuela one of
South America's most important economies
the President of the United States
doesn't want to melt down in Venezuela
on his watch and that's understandable
unfortunately that regime is
unsustainable today and a policy that it
encourages the Democratic opposition to
have a dialogue with a repressive regime
really isn't sustainable the United
States could be part of a process part
of the solution to hold the material
government accountable to its own
constitution and to its commitments to
defend democracy
president Obama has an opportunity to
use diplomatic tools working with key
neighbors that are becoming more active
in the defense of democracy president
also has some unique asymmetrical tools
that he can use to sanction individuals
within the Venezuelan regime do not want
to see a democratic transition it
remains to be seen whether President
Obama will be part of that solution or
whether he will preside over the
consolidation of a dictatorship in South
America we all want stability in
Venezuela but at the cost of keeping a
corrupt and incompetent government power
what do you think let us know in the
comments section and let us know what
other topics you want aei scholars to
cover in 60 seconds